- So, and actually, Seth Rogen
produces the show, right?
So did you have to audition for him?
Was that nerve wracking?
- I did.
It was, he is a,
you guys picked the most
intimidating picture
I've ever seen of Seth Rogen.
(laughing)
He's like, audition for me please.
- Oh my God, you sounded like him.
- [Female] Yeah, that was good.
- I do my best.
No, I had to audition for him,
which was super nerve wracking
'cause he's one of my heroes,
him and his writing
partner, Evan Goldberg,
and I remember I was
pacing in the hallway,
going over my lines and
he hadn't showed up yet,
and then like seemingly a
mile away I could hear like,
(vocalizes laughter)
I could hear his iconic laugh
and I was like, oh he's here.
And then once we got into the room,
it was insane because he was
reading Butcher on the day.
Butcher is a character
in the show who has a
very thick, Cockney accent
so it was Seth Rogen not doing the accent,
but saying lines that involved a lot of
hardcore Cockney slang,
which my brain was really
struggling to understand,
you know, what reality I was in.
It would be like, I would
say a line and he would say,
we got to get them in the boot
and then we're going to bugger off.
It was really-
(laughing)
- Is he trying to throw you off your game?
Is this what it was, like?
- I don't think so.
He's a very, very nice guy.
It was just one of those
moments where I was so nervous
and I was just, I was so crazy.
No, I don't think he would
intentionally do that,
but memorable to say the least.
- He seems like somebody
that might mess with someone.
That's the only reason why I'm saying it.